three different cases and whether all
this is a true reflection of the actions
of a corrupt power hungry
self-interested man all the actions of
government officials who want to shut
him down at any cost or perhaps elements
of both we know Trump and his supporters
say it's a political Witch Hunt against
him calculated interference to stop him
getting a second run at the White House
but what does all this mean for the U.S
justice system that's Prosecuting him we
are going to be asking these questions
on the show tonight here in the studio I
am joined on the panel by Isabelle
oakshot Paula Roan Adrian and Richard
Tice as well are you all I mean it's
it's wrong to say looking forward to
this but you've all joined us here in
the studio to talk about this uh has it
gripped you in the way that the previous
indictment to have Richard do you think
it's more serious this is clearly more
serious because it's Federal I think
we're all gripped by the spectacle I
mean the fact that you know where no one
else almost in the world Richard sorry
to interrupt you there we did just have
Donald Trump uh poking his head out the
plane there we go walking down the
stairs former president uh the U.S
president Donald Trump there wearing a
red Republican Tie Suit making its way
into his motorcade this is the last
we'll see from him for a bit we're
reliably informed that this uh Airfield
is actually very close to the courthouse
that he's going to be making his way to
so we won't expect to see him now for
the next few minutes whilst he makes his
way to the courthouse but interestingly
they're just the same get off the plane
we love these types of shots in news and
they're the rest of his team I wonder
what the conversations were like on that
plane Richard it is but there it is
there's the spectacle no one else could
command this level of attention just
walking down the steps and it's it's
extraordinary the height uh the spin
both sides but I really wonder how many
Americans are actually going to have
their views Changed by by all of this
noise I mean whether it's 78 counts 50
counts 20 counts
how much difference does that all make
three cases and then you've got on the
other side you've got the uh the case
against Hunter Biden the judge throwing
that out the potential implications for
the current sitting president I wonder
it feels just like showed this does it I
mean it's just a spectacle to me and I'm
not a massive Trump fan or anything like
that this is a show trial that's what it
is you know you read through the
indictment I've looked at it in quite a
lot of detail and frankly it looks very
cooked up and I think a lot of a lot of
Republican supporters or those who lean
towards Donald Trump will have their
views reinforced we know that from the
polling already he is way out he is way
ahead of all his closest Rivals combined
for the Republican nomination so you
know there's a counter a conspiracy
theory if you like that actually the
Democrats know that this is going to
reinforce his popular appeal and they
want him there as a republican nominee
because they think they're man or woman
perhaps would be a woman can defeat him
Paula do you think uh that's all the
point though that the indictments are
fueling his popularity because as
Isabelle says he's pulling much further
ahead than the other contenders and and
Isabella is right in terms of the
statistics they do show that there seems
to be some kind of crazy link between
every time he gets a new diamond or
there's some kind of civil lawsuit that
is raised against him his percentages
increase
um but to answer your initial question
about the spectacle of this all I I
think I actually find it incredibly
distasteful and it's worse than watching
a car crash because what we need to
remind ourselves about is that seven
people lost their lives on the 6th of
January and they lost their lives due to
the insurgents and and that's what I
want us to constantly remind ourselves
about so this is actually not what this
is about well the case what it is in
this pursuing a prosecution of that
though is it that's not on the rap sheet
but it is in the sense of what he was in
exciting them to do and we and we
shouldn't lose sight of that and the
fact is is that ultimately this was an
outrageous display of behavior in the
terms of undermining democracy
even even if the 6th of July that it
can't it can't stand the losers
of the voices in Washington DC and see
what they've got to say about this
police to say we're joined by Ari
Fleischer and Joe Walsh as well Harry uh
uh good to speak to you both Joe and
Harry Aria also start with you just get
a sense from you what you think the
gravity of the situation is you sat here
listening to three Brits talking about
it talk to us from the American point of
view thank you
yeah I'm distressed I mean I just think
about what people in other countries
look at America and they've always held
America up with an ideal and they I
cannot imagine what you think when you
watch one leader of One party in date
the leader of another party and
potentially put him in prison a former
United States President you know I think
these manners should be settled by the
people Donald Trump has done some
objectionable things but I don't think
they're criminal and if you don't like
Donald Trump vote him down let's go
let's resort to the courts to go to
something that's never been done before
I just find extraordinary and America is
reaching a point where we have never
gone before and I find it very
unsettling let's speak to uh former
Republican 2020 presidential candidate
on some of those points Joe because
their points I know you've heard a lot
the last few days as you've been doing
the broadcast rounds this idea of a
weaponized justice system and the idea
that this there isn't any criminal
activity being alleged here what do you
say to that
well I agree with my friend Ari that the
rest of the world must be scratching
their heads but they've been scratching
their heads for a long time two and a
half years ago a sitting American
president LED an effort to violently
overthrow an American election now I
disagree with my friend Ari in that I
think this is a good day for America
this is a day to celebrate uh no one is
above the law and that man who led a
violent effort to overthrow an American
election is is finally being held
accountable that's a good thing
look Harry your friend Joe Points this
out can you agree with that it's a good
thing to at least have this air to hear
it sort of being interrogated or
investigated as Paul on our panel just
said seven people did die in the um
action the rioting that took place on
January 6th
what JoJo said was simple but wrong if
that was the case then why wasn't Donald
Trump charged with incitement to Riot
the charge against him was not about the
riot the charge against him dealt with
the statements that he made that were
deceptive about what he actually
believes that he won the election that
the election was stolen all of which led
later to a riot look I've always said
that Joe Biden won the election and I
don't believe this election was stolen
I've never been in the camp of Donald
Trump when it comes to that but
that is a separate matter from whether
Donald Trump was one of the rioters with
whether Donald Trump led the riot if
that was the case he would have been
charged with that he wasn't charged with
that he's essentially being charged with
the Free Speech violation that his
advocacy the statements he made were
knowingly false is what the indictment
says and therefore they're charging him
with that type of of allegation so you
don't charge people with making
statements like that if you did half the
Democratic party would have to go to
prison because they charged that Donald
Trump stole the 2016 election and
they've said about numerous other
elections
the noise it should not be criminal
you're watching pictures here of the
motorcade and the Press Team all heading
towards the courthouse there in
Washington DC we're going to be staying
with these live pictures Joe go on
well again I agree with Ari Trump's not
being indicted for inciting a violent
attempt to overthrow an election but Ari
is wrong
Trump is not being indicted based on
anything he said he's been indicted for
what he did crimes he committed the the
allegations are and he'll have his day
in court that he lied he purposely lied
in court in court filing if true that's
a crime
he pressured state legislators to exceed
their constitutional Authority if true
that's a crime he led a conspiracy to
create fake electors that were sent to
the United States Senate if true that's
a crime and Donald Trump it is alleged
pressured Justice Department officials
to conduct sham investigations and lie
to the American people if true that's a
crime this isn't about what Trump said
this is about what he did uh Harry let's
respond to that then because it's not
only what Trump's said what he did this
strikes the heart of the U.S first
amendment as well that is the right you
can have a false opinion you can have
false ideas but the argument that is now
being waged is what that then incites
people to do the actions that then
follow and surely it's had an effect in
the way people think because some new
polling out by CNN this evening saying
that nearly 70 percent of Republicans
and Republican leading people believe
that Biden did not win the the last
election
yeah and and this is where you have
unequal Justice where Justice that's
supposed to be blind is not blind I was
there in 2000 after the 2000 election
between Al Gore and George W bush that
was settled by the Supreme Court you had
numerous Democrats challenge the results
of that election that bush re-election
in 2004 numerous Democrats lied and said
George Bush lost Ohio and made and
challenged the results of that elections
that came up in the Senate so if
believing ardently that someone has
stolen an election and acting upon it is
a crime then half of Washington has to
go to jail both parties and I say that
as somebody who recognized that Joe
Biden won I think Donald Trump's wrong
but Donald Trump if he ardently believes
that the election was stolen he's got a
right to make that case and then to act
upon that and the systems of the
American government held Joe makes it
sound like it's a crime to do the things
Donald Trump did to pressure the
Department of Justice well that's also
called advocating for something you
believe if he believes it and again my
point being
an America the people are sovereign the
people solve these issues and what we've
already done in America is turn
impeachment into the British style vote
of confidence if you fail a vote of
confidence you're leave as prime
minister impeachment is different but
we've turned it into just that and now
we're turning the courts the criminal
justice system into another way of
resolving a political dispute not like
Donald Trump get rid of him
Joe can you buy can you buy that
argument that this is uh essentially
about protecting the U.S constitutional
rights and it is a political argument
that's been brought into the courts of
Justice
no no look if we go by what Ari is
hoping for here if you're a candidate
for president then you're not to be held
accountable for your crimes look Ari can
disagree with this indictment but Jack
Smith and the prosecutors have specific
crimes that Donald Trump committed and
if they can prove their case in court
these are specific crimes Trump has a
day has the right to prove that right
that he didn't commit these crimes but
this baloney that trumps being penalized
because of what he said that's just not
true we're talking about specific
actions he took just one Ari you create
you lead a conspiracy to create a slate
of fake electors and then you present
those electors those fake electors to
the United States Senate if true that is
a crime whether you like it or not
they were never presented to the United
States Senate and it is legitimate when
the clock is ticking down and if you do
believe you want to State and then you
have a date certain about which your
electors have to be in place it's
prudent to prepare for that people call
them fake electors but it's also if you
think you won the state you have your
electors this is a political dispute not
a criminal one look before we wrap up
he'll have his day in court to make that
case sorry uh there's been plenty of
days in court both of you uh not for
either of you Brian but the Donald Trump
plenty let's talk about it uh Joe Walsh
just before we wrap up because you were
a former Republican runner for
presidency you've been outspoken since
about the fact that uh you know kind of
going against the Trump style of
leadership has led you to a path where
you're basically not accepting the
mainstream GOP that's a Republican party
uh what is it to be a traditional
Republican now in the US
well to be look and I fully acknowledge
this is Donald Trump's party and someone
who opposes Trump has no room in the
party I fully acknowledge that and I
don't think that's going to change and
maybe Ari disagrees with me on this but
all these indictments are going to do is
strengthen him I think this indictment
will lock up the nomination for him and
I think Donald Trump's going to be
really difficult to beat in the general
election
Harry uh the nomination locked up for
this
I I think it's highly likely that's
going to be Trump but there is going to
be an alternative who emerges and I
advise everybody just wait late this
fall early this winter there's always an
alternative to the front runner someone
will emerge it to either be Ambassador
Nikki Haley Senator Tim Scott I think
those are the two likely ones to rise
there are other possibilities
um as far as Joe's saying he's likely to
be the next president I don't know about
that I think where America is still a 50
50 country when it comes to the general
election I I can see 82 year old Joe
Biden at the time winning the election I
could also see Donald Trump winning the
election despite three indictments now
he's dead even in the polls with Joe
Biden fascinating stuff Ariat Fleischer
thanks so much for joining us Joe stay
with us we're going to come back to you
later on in the show and we are still of
course bring you all of these live
pictures as Donald Trump the former US
president makes his way from the
Airfield there in Washington DC to the
courthouse where he's going to face his
hearing for his third indictment this
time on a conspiracy see alleged
conspiracy to overturn the results of
the 2020 election now and censored next
tonight other than Donald Trump's
one-man face has become synonymous with
January 6 that's the QA non Shaman do
you remember him he's already faced his
own Justice for that day but after the
break he's here to tell us if he thinks
the former president should too
foreign
[Music]
Trump yeah look at him fail stop working
just because their skin folk don't mean
they're kinfolks do you believe you can
win this war but it's making me cry
again I'm trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election can we yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
thank you
let it roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off shorts
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drunk you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan on Center
we bring you live a special coverage but
one man that is stuck in the Public's
Mind Donald Trump of course today third
indictment here in Washington DC this
Courthouse we're going to bring you live
pictures throughout his motorcade has
been making its way from the Airfield in
Washington DC he flew on one of his
Planes a sort of trump branded plane
from Bedminster New Jersey earlier on
today and he's going to be arriving at
the courthouse this is a federal
courthouse he is going to be
fingerprinted that was him coming off
the plane just a few minutes ago looking
chipper I mean I'm no body expert
analysis but he is somewhat used to this
now the the public circus of course he's
been used to that his whole life but
also just the narrative the
conversations we're all having about his
alleged criminality water off the Ducks
back I'd go as far as to say uh smoothly
making his way into his car and on his
way to the courthouse as I said there he
will be fingerprinted he he will stand
within the courthouse of course we won't
be showing you from inside there we'll
show you all the pictures from outside
the courthouse and of course if he makes
any kind of speech as well there have
been some demonstrators some supporters
uh sort of waving flags outside the
courthouse so far today we'll bring you
anything else we see now though we want
to turn this conversation to remind you
about January 6th that was January 6
2021 when we saw those large groups of
people amass on the Capitol Hill you
will remember this man's face
particularly his name is Jacob chancelly
he is the so-called Q Anon Shaman and
for his role on that day he was
sentenced to 41 months in prison he's
since been released early joins us now
to give us his unique perspective on the
man many say inspired his actions Donald
Trump Jacob thanks for making time for
us uh I know it's strangely a busy time
for you to be talking about this
um but first of all um let's just remind
our viewers because we were very
International audience here you were the
face of this January six Uprising you
were the guy in the fur coat and the
horns and everything else you were the
so-called shame and how do you feel
about all that now
oh it's clear that the operation
Mockingbird media chose to make me their
straw man they chose to use my face and
my image to create a shock and awe
campaign that they then used to divide
the country into people that support
Donald Trump and people that don't and
anybody that uh sees that what was done
to me and doesn't agree with it they now
are beginning to see how it is that the
American justice system is corrupt and
has been corrupt for decades look when
you were sentenced you you were very
remorseful you said quote I was wrong
for entering the capital I have no
excuse whatsoever in retrospect I do
everything differently I would try with
all my heart and soul to stop people
that also joined you that day do you
feel still feel the same
well if I would have known what was
going to happen I definitely would have
tried to stop everything from happening
before it happened and you know what I
did was technically illegal so of course
you know there's no defense for an
illegal action
um but I have you know accepted
responsibility I have served my time and
because of my good behavior in prison as
well as my programming while I was in
prison the the the programming that I
did in the prison I got a year off my
sentence and was released early so I
think that's indicative of the fact that
what it is at the operation Mockingbird
media said about me is just completely
unfounded can you class this is
Operation Mockingbird media
well yeah absolutely but you know the
thing is is Operation Mockingbird has
been going on for a very long time it's
when the CIA infiltrated the media
Outlets during the Civil Rights movement
during the anti-war movement in the 60s
and the 70s and they were hell-bent on
controlling the narrative in the country
because it's all about controlling the
minds of the people controlling the
minds of the public through
psychological warfare techniques
combining trigger words with trigger
images to create an emotional response
in the subconscious mind that can then
be weaponized against groups of
individuals or individuals like Donald
Trump or myself now I'm uh listening to
all that and then you say it because
it's uh your First Amendment right to
add that point of view I'm of course a
journalist I work here I can tell you I
was never recruited by the CIA
um but it is always interesting to hear
this because it is the Q Anon movement
this conspiracy movement some call it
some call it a cult it captured the
minds of so many people are you still in
the movement it sounds like your views
haven't changed do you think they've got
stronger
well Q Anon is a fiction created by the
media so they could discredit q and the
anons that were following q and on is a
fiction created by the media so that
they could basically smear the very
founded realizations and Revelations of
a debt-based fiat currency controlling
our monetary system the child in human
trafficking networks that are all over
the planet and are used by these Elite
groups that control the banks and the
Federal Reserve to Blackmail people into
submission like what was happening with
Jeffrey Epstein if you look into what
happened with Jeffrey Epstein and the
fact that his Client List has not been
made public or the fact that uh like the
finders which is on the government
website and how children were being
abducted and and abused and put in cages
if you look into
um the testimony of Ronald Bernard if
you look into Franklin cover up in
Nebraska Jay could we could keep this
thing all night oh yeah we could keep
going all right
saying those are your opinions those are
allegations here in the United Kingdom
do it yourself yeah you're a journalists
you'll look into it yourself these
things are very real you can look them
up very easily and if you're a
journalist and you really want to you
really care about your country whether
it be in the UK or in the United States
then you'll look into these things and
realize that to quote to quote Kennedy
let me just quote Kennedy really quick
we are opposed around the world by a
monolithic and ruthless conspiracy that
relies primarily on Covert means for
expanding its sphere of influence on
infiltration instead of invasions on
subversions instead of Elections on
intimidation instead of free choice on
gorillas by night instead of arms
go and you can have two you can have
five more seconds finish your point okay
is a system that's just conspired vast
human and material resources to create a
tightly knit highly efficient machine
that combines military diplomatic
scientific economic and political
operations okay these preparations all
different viewpoints and opinions much
like the first amendment there in the
U.S so we are going to open it up now to
our panel who joined me in the studio
who were listening to all of that and
ask you what you make of it all when
that is somebody who claims to be one of
Trump's major supporters Paula I have to
say that what I would like to ask Jacob
is I'm intrigued about the whole
corruption I'm intrigued about the
political power and yet he doesn't seem
to be uncomfortable with the fact that
every time Trump sends out a press
release there's a fundraising link
attached to it I mean why is nobody
uncomfortable about that normal part of
American politics
why is nobody uncomfortable about that
was my question why is it the case that
we are quite happy to attach
fundraising to what should be something
quality
it's uncomfortable for me that a man who
ran a number of businesses into the
ground could then take over a country
and is now suggesting that this country
is somehow corrupt is that it is just
the American system it might feel
uncomfortable for us but they are
allowed you know private businesses
private donors private everything to
fund themselves to the moon and they do
need but it's literally that is
literally what happens in the UK I send
out an email
regulated yeah I sent out an email every
other week asking for donations I've got
my own business I'm running a political
party we're seeking votes we would like
to help run this country better so
that's it's what you've just said is
there's nothing corrupt about that
process our donations are clearly
declared above a certain level I would
suggest that there are questions that
Jacob may have wanted to ask Trump about
that and may have wanted to stress about
that but he seems quite comfortable to
to allow Trump to behave in ways that
may be questionable I have said that as
as a man who has run a number of
businesses those businesses and the way
he's run them has been questionable
um and he has faced a number of very
serious questions about that he doesn't
seem to be worried about that and that
he's taken that questionable Behavior
into his pregnancy he doesn't seem
uncomfortable about that let's bring Joe
Walsh back into this conversation I feel
like we could use with an American Voice
here Joe thank you for staying here were
you listening to us there to talk about
that getting nitpicky about the way that
American politics is funded
uh well I just want to compliment you
you handled Jacob deftly look the whole
thing made me sad Jacob needs help I
hope he's getting help but it makes me
sad because look I come from the world
of trump supporters I voted for Trump in
2016.
so many of these people are in a cult
and and they just can't get out and
Trump can do or say no wrong it just
makes me sad I wanted to ask you about
that Joe actually on the what about is
in point because
um you know we did a show on this last
night I spoke to Pastor Mark Burns who
is close to Trump when I asked him a
question about Donald Trump and about
the way this indictment was going he
immediately said well Biden Hunter
Biden's laptop Biden everything else
what we're used to seeing and I want the
viewer to understand that this is a
common tactic deploy this is not me
saying the only Republicans do this
Democrats do as well everyone does it
across the political Spectrum when you
ask somebody a question and they
immediately point at someone else how um
weak that tactic is and do you think
that when you saw somebody like Jacob
speaking just now the Q Anon Shaman that
it undoes his course cause to speak the
way he does or do you think it
galvanizes supporters more
oh I I think it galvanizes the forces
look at everything Jacob's been through
and he's still uttering bull crap like
that uh he's not alone I I hear from
these folks every single day go to a
trump rally like I have there are so
many Americans who think that way we're
in so much more trouble in this country
than the world really understands how do
we find a way out of it I mean it's not
just you this is uh happening elsewhere
in the world as well and I'm not saying
I'm taking a complete position against
critical thinking and rational inquiry
but this conspiracy like cult-like and
behavior you're talking about
look I think Trump's greatest Legacy is
the destruction of Truth all politicians
lie we've never had someone like Donald
Trump Who Lies every time he opens his
mouth so now we live in a country where
where half of America
doesn't believe basic truths 80 percent
of my former political party believes
Donald Trump won in 2020. how do we get
beyond that we need conversations we got
to figure out a way to talk across the
Divide because there are people who can
get out of the cult uh but right now
it's it's so political we have to do all
we can to make sure Trump's not
re-elected yeah even Elon Musk the other
day not my favorite person of the world
but he did tweet something I agreed with
which is that if you're in a political
party and you agree with everything that
political party is saying without
questioning one part of it and running
to its defense any other opportunity you
are in a cult do you think that type of
cultish behavior exists on the left as
much as it does on the right as well
it exists everywhere in America but
right now it is by far the most
pronounced on the right and I say that
as someone who comes from the right and
still is of the right the right has been
beaten down in this country for so long
Donald Trump was the first national
figure who came along and said I hear
you and I'm going to seek revenge on the
left in this country from that moment on
he became their cult leader and now they
are just tied to him let's go back to
the panelist studio Joe thanks stay with
us for the rest of the show uh Isabelle
I notice you've been sort of yeah I did
actually find the conversation with
Jacob really interesting because whilst
he's undoubtedly wrong about a great
deal he's also very clever isn't he this
up this is a very intelligent guy and it
upends that image of all Trump's Die
Hard supporters being incredibly stupid
rednecks you know no idea about the
bigger picture future in the world this
is one very articulate guy and a lot of
people go along with those conspiracy
extraordinary claims he had Paula and I
were looking at each other about the
Caged children uh you know some really
outlandish stuff there but some of what
he was saying is much easier for many
ordinary Americans to believe that there
is this Elite that is somehow
controlling things and depriving them of
their Democratic vote and in the end
actually the reason Trump was objecting
to the result was because he was
standing up as he saw it for True
democracy and that's why this is so
divisive you know you've got one side
saying he's trying to subvert democracy
the other side Trump and his supporters
saying actually quite the reverse this
guy was championing democracy which is
being corrupted by this invisible Elite
look it's I think you raised some
interesting points there and as a
journalist it's very difficult to uh
interview someone like that exactly as
you said the fundamental articulate
intelligent I want to hear what he has
to say but you have to counter what a
clearly in my mind on truths but Richard
it strikes the heart of perception of
reality which is at the core of the
indictment we're seeing today Trump did
he believe what he was saying about for
example the Georgia vote count I mean
the reality is Trump throughout his
whole life has been a Salesman and
clearly a very good salesman and we all
know that great salesmen always over
promise and under deliver in many cases
and he's still he's still always on the
ax he's still sort of you know playing
to the audience the crowd everything he
does is about that he knows he's got his
his Believers as Joseph's his cult
followers and he's playing to that crowd
and he always appears strong he he
appears confident and that's what a lot
of people like in a leader and they
don't have to believe everything that
person does or says and I think that's
where we're at with Trump now and but
here's the real thing whatever Joe says
the fact is that Trump could be indicted
he could be found guilty he could go to
jail he could still win the presidential
election ultimately that means the
voters have their say the voters are
sovereign democracy still exists and
you're right you know it's a high
popularity contest and he's a strong man
uh leader that we'll we'll keep our
panel with us because there's so much
more to discuss and after the break
we're going to be hearing from a strong
Republican voice Stateside our friend
Tommy Lauren joins the show to talk
about all of this as well as some of the
other Republican contenders as well
stick around for that
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored we are still
showing these live pictures from outside
the courtroom in Washington DC where
Donald Trump former US president is
shortly expected to arrive he is
fingerprinting for his hearing for his
third indictment allegations this time
that he conspired with co-conspirators
to overturn the 2020 U.S election result
in which he was defeated by Joe Biden
this has been a long time coming in
investigation into the capital capital
riots on the 6th of January 2021 as a
culmination all that potentially his
most serious indictment yet and a
reminder there have been some 78
criminal charges over three criminal
trials he is going to be facing as he
makes the second run at the white house
uh framing that they're all out to be
joined now by the host of Tommy Lauren
or the host of Tomi lahren as Fearless
on outkick and still joined in the
studio by talk TV's International editor
Isabelle oakshot talk TV contributor
Paul Lauren Adrian and talk TV presenter
Richard Tice now Tommy coming to you I'm
sure you're very busy at the moment
giving you follow all things politics in
the US
um but just let's get you your outlook
basically on this indictment you knew it
was coming I'm sure what did you think
when you read through it
well first of all I thought convenient
timing I mean imagine that earlier this
week we get bombshell testimony from
Devin Archer Hunter Biden's business
associate basically incriminating Joe
Biden for being on speakerphone over 20
times apparently just talking about the
weather you know as they say but uh
convenient timing but now we've got
another Trump indictment if you look at
the timeline of this it's always
convenient the way this happens what a
coincidence but looking through this
particular indictment whatever you think
of Donald Trump I think this indictment
in particular looks to be written by a
kindergartner because it goes on to
acknowledge that Donald Trump has the
right to free speech but then ends with
the fact that no he really doesn't have
the right to free speech so I think it's
a farce just like the other two
indictments and just like the fourth
likely will be this is clearly in a
political weaponization attempt to take
out the Republican front runner and
unfortunately for the Democrats
just dipping in now to hear from a
spokesperson standing outside the court
house where Donald Trump will shortly be
heard he may not agree with Mike Pence
he may not agree with one of his lawyers
but that doesn't mean that there weren't
other people advising him exactly the
opposite and the president has a right
as every one of us do to listen to
several opinions and make their decision
I remember hearing Hillary Clinton and
Stacy Abrams argue their elections were
not right I mean how in the
weaponsization of the doj didn't happen
then no of course not but if your last
name's Trump it's very different so
Hillary Clinton could have a problem
when she lost the election and we could
have a complete liberal meltdown as we
all saw but when we have dignified
disagreements we take them to court we
say do things patriotically and
peacefully he is to blame for things
that he did not himself do and that's
what we're seeing frankly folks this is
not about that this is about politics
this is about 2024 period the end
thank you
reply
continuing to listen there to the
spokesperson just talking there about
what you were talking about Tommy
basically what they're calling the Trump
campaign the politicization of the
Department of Justice Stateside and the
politicization of this whole trial a
persecution of politically motivated
Witch Hunt if I can borrow those words
um let's just talk then we cut you off I
know you're used to it because you've
been a broadcast yourself for many many
years but let's just talk about the rest
of the Republican contenders and what
they've been saying off the back of all
this DeSantis but also Pence we've heard
from Tulsi gabbard as well Pence Has
Come Out Swinging against Trump but
DeSantis not so much
yeah you know I think that unfortunately
what's happening to Donald Trump has
largely meant that every Republican
everywhere has to make a comment about
it and I don't think that's necessarily
Fair uh of course we know that because
DeSantis is the front runner against
Donald Trump his biggest competitor a
lot has been put under Santa's shoulders
to have to speak out on behalf of Donald
Trump I don't think that's wholly fair I
mean he's running his own campaign for
the Republican nomination for president
in 2024 so he has mentioned the
politicization of the doj he's mentioned
the two-tiered system of justice but I
don't think it's realistic or reasonable
to expect him to go to bat for Donald
Trump fully and wholeheartedly given he
is his competition and I think it's okay
to say that as somebody who likes both
Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis I think
it's unfair that DeSantis has been put
in this position I I agree with you on
the point that I think it's not
unexpected to hear him coming out
against uh his nearest rival for the
Republican candidacy uh in fact I would
suggest that DeSantis hasn't gone far
enough would you I think he'd be more
tempted I know there are reasons why he
might not want to come out and attack
Trump publicly I can understand the
criticizing of the criminal justice
system if that's part of his campaign
strategy
um but he's got to beat Trump if he
wants to become president
yeah I think desantis's biggest argument
is not going to be just going after
Donald Trump because a lot of
Republicans and Trump supporters do
believe that this is being weaponized
against Donald Trump and he is being
witch hunted yet again I think to
Santa's best strategy here is to say Hey
listen what's happening to Donald Trump
my competitor is wrong and that is
exactly why I need to be president so
that I can actually get elected I have a
better shot at getting elected get into
the White House and then fix some of
these things actually drain the swamp
that is going to be the best Lane and
most effective Lane for Rhonda Santos to
take not to attack Donald Trump for
what's going on because a lot of us
believe it's wrong but to say hey I'm
the guy that can fix it and not only
that I can win and it doesn't matter
none of this matters all of our gripes
and complaints they do not matter unless
we win in 2024 so I think that's the
best Lane for him to take at this point
and just a reminder for our
International viewers we're talking
about Ron DeSantis who's the governor of
Florida and one of the near contenders
to take on Trump for the Run for the
White House for the Republicans let's
take a listen to him
a republican a DC jury would indict a
ham sandwich and convict a ham sandwich
if it was a republican ham sandwich I
think Americans need to be able to
remove cases out of D.C I think the
juries are stacked I think that they're
going to want to convict people that
they disagree with
Let's cross to our panel in the studio
Paula a ham sandwich
I was gonna say I was intrigued at
Tommy's definition of the indictment
being looks as if it was written in the
kindergarten but of course the grand
jury didn't agree with her on that point
and a number of grand juries haven't
agreed with her and a number of juries
haven't agreed with her in the terms in
in the sense of trump coming before them
and and decisions being made against him
and you know apart from this we've also
got two other civil suits that he's got
to deal with I mean it's just
endless pile of legal issues
well let me tell you because if if I
remember correctly the what about Hunter
Biden the district attorney who came to
negotiate the settlement was appointed
by
Trump I think that there are that's
right though is that that plays into
narrative form that it's politicized on
both sides right there are so many
applications against uh against Hunter
Biden with the involvement of his father
the president which are getting nowhere
near a proportionate amount of attention
by mainstream media on both sides of the
Atlantic you know I'm guilty of not
being fully clued up about all the
allegations against them guess what
because they're not actually being
covered in much detail here and I
haven't given enough time to looking at
them and I am very uh probably
representative of many other people so
yeah it's a really interesting point how
DeSantis responds to this because it's
so tribal I think his best approach is
to attack the Democrats attack the whole
she was fighting issues
yeah I do appreciate it and I think
that's right and say actually you know
Iron DeSantis I'm the person who's most
likely the best chance of beating the
Democrats and then during this one but
it is a very difficult line that he's
got to he's got a trailer rare flash of
Charisma there from him about the ham
sandwich
great sound bite I want to just finish
on that point as well you may because
yeah of course it's relevant still to
talk about Biden I was joshing when I
said you said what about Hunter Biden
because we made the point earlier in the
show that it is generally used as what
aboutism at the moment is there ever a
good time to talk about the Biden
allegations the allegations surrounding
that family of course uh I would say as
a journalist all the time these things
must be inquired interrogated and
hopefully tried if if they're required
I'm honestly actually much more
concerned about the physical and mental
state of of Joe Biden I mean why can't
we talk about that openly and have a
vigorous debate about whether it is okay
in this country
relentlessly suggests that his Medics
don't know what they're talking about
but they suggest that he doesn't know
what it's just that he doesn't know what
he's talking about
in this country he would not be allowed
to be in the house let's go back to
Tommy Tommy were you listening in on all
that are you somewhat reassured by
hearing a load of Brits talking about
the fact that we do need to interrogate
the allegations against the bidens
I am so happy to hear it and it is
unfortunate that the world is not
getting the real story and the full
picture of exactly what the Biden crime
regime has been up to when you hear it I
mean just take out the names just hear
that somebody who is a sitting vice
president was on speakerphone while his
son was discussing business with foreign
entities and business associates and
then receiving millions of dollars and
then you've got Devin Archer saying that
Joe Biden was the brand he was the flex
he was what they were selling was Joe
Biden the then vice president this is
concerning talk about Donald Trump
conspiracy to defraud the United States
if these allegations are true and we're
soon going to find out I hope boy that
seems like much more of an issue much
more egregious than anything Donald
Trump has been charged with well we'll
have to wait and see but as it stands
today it is Donald Trump that is uh
standing outside a courtroom currently
in Washington DC ready to be indicted
again Tommy Lauren uh joining us for
that Insight thank you thank you once
again to our panel as well bringing
those pictures from outside the
courtroom as we head into a breakthrough
do stay with us next tonight we are
nearing the top of the hour when Trump's
appointment with Justice begins we'll be
back in DC for that and bring you all
the live latest pictures of his
supporters and his detractors next
[Music]
foreign
Trump yeah look at him fail not working
just because their skin folk don't mean
they're kinfolks do you believe you can
win this war but he's making me cry
again they're trying to force you out
yes I feel betrayed keep it
award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored tonight of
course we are focusing on all things
Donald Trump that is the Trump plane
that was coming into land just around
two hours ago in Washington DC from
Bedminster New Jersey the former U.S
president was on board and this was him
getting off the plane just embarking not
waving to reporters it's not a scene for
jubilation is it your third indictment
and this of course as he faces a series
of charges from the U.S federal
government for a range of allegations
this latest one uh alleging a conspiracy
with co-conspirators to overturn the
results of the 2020 us election in which
Joe Biden uh claimed victory that was
Donald Trump getting into his motorcade
and we've been following as his car has
been making his its way to the courtroom
where he will be fingerprinted and he
will be heard in this indictment we
don't expect him to speak much we've
heard already from members of The
Campaign there are supporters outside
the courthouse as well and those
expected Justice special counsel Jack
Smith has entered the courtroom and as
the hearing is about to begin we'll be
bringing live pictures as and when but I
am joined by from Washington DC by the
former Republican 2020 presidential
candidate Joe Walsh still with us on the
show it's been great to have your
Insight so far and in the studio by the
former advisor to Donald Trump Dr Jan
Halper Hayes Isabel and Paula also
staying with us here in the studio uh
let's start with you Dr Jan um very kind
of you to make time this evening uh you
have had a close uh professional
relationship to Donald Trump you have
been a founding member member of
Republicans overseas here in the United
Kingdom you're based here in the UK
watching all this from London what did
you think of this latest indictment uh
it was expected we were waiting and we
thought that they were going to try and
do the 14th Amendment and charge him for
treason and Sedition even though he's
been charged as a criminal the fact is
that he's allowed due process and so
that means that he can subpoena anyone
he wants and he can present any of the
evidence that he wants to present
um I know that on one hand one reads the
indictments but there's nothing there's
nothing really there concrete just like
uh Alvin Braggs he just cut and pasted
37 times so the the thing is that they
have not succeeded in destroying him and
they will keep on trying to destroy him
let me ask you this because I thought
this stuck out from from the indictment
the co-conspirators allegedly involved
not named but plenty of Gossip over who
they might be right were you surprised
at that because it does hint that there
might be people in trumps in a circle
that he can no longer Trust
uh I'm not sure that I would go there
um because there were even rumors that
Mark Meadows had turned against him
um I I don't take those things seriously
until people tell me that there is
serious evidence about that
um the co-conspirators were also thrown
in there because they're trying to scare
anyone connected to Trump and bankrupt
them because of legal bills can I ask
where you were on January 6 2021 where
did you watch that from
uh
from London and how did you feel
well see I had information that
um there were federal agents there I had
a lot of information
I did not I I knew they were going to
blow it up as an Insurrection how do you
have some people rebelling initially and
suddenly five minutes later they declare
it's an Insurrection why did Nancy
Pelosi have her daughter with her film
crew there filming Nancy Pelosi through
it
um you know I had gotten enough texts
and enough pictures
um to know some aspects of it being
staged I think that it's that's a strong
allegation to make especially given the
indictment that we're seeing and I want
to bring in Joe Walsh into this
conversation he is listening in
um and ask him to respond for that the
allegations you're making January 6 was
in some way uh yeah no I I had to repeat
the word staged but had some kind of
thinking behind it Joe
look what your guests just said again
makes me profoundly sad as sad as I was
when I sat there on January 6 and watch
our Capital attacked watched thousands
of people Storm Into the capital because
they believed a lie think about that
Trump's lie was behind all of this and
these poor people went into that Capital
to try to stop our elections process but
what your guest just said is exactly
what the vast majority of Republican
voters believe it's wrong it's a bunch
of bull it's a lie but Donald Trump has
convinced Republican voters of that
which is why this indictment will help
him politically
look both of you
um Joe thank you for your inputs on that
Dr Jan thank you for joining us here in
the studio unfortunately that is all the
time we've got this hour usually at this
point in the evening we actually sign
off from uncensored and hand over to the
talk but tonight we're staying on air to
cover this huge breaking stories it
happens don't fret after the break Mike
Graham and nickel of Thorpe will be
joining me to lend their analysis to
Trump in the dark
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored with me
Rosanna Lockwood and we're at this very
moment Donald Trump is in the courthouse
at the foot of Capitol Hill the site of
years-long government effort to hold
accountable those who tried to subvert
democracy we are showing you live
pictures here from outside the
courthouse Donald Trump is inside at the
defense table as expected Justice
special counsel Jack Smith also there he
was the prosecutor who bought these
charges and uh revealed them the other
day and we've been hearing from Trump's
lawyer in this indictment let's hear
what he said
your last name's Trump it's very
different so Hillary Clinton could have
a problem when she lost the election and
we could have a complete liberal
meltdown as we all saw but when we have
dignified disagreements we take them to
court we say do things patriotically and
peacefully he's to blame for things that
he did not himself do and that's what
we're seeing frankly folks this is not
about that this is about politics this
is about 2024. my apologies there for
misgendering Elena Haber the Trump
lawyer that's my unconscious sexual bias
and they're assuming a lawyer would be a
man I have been a it's been to Alan
dershowitz a lot the last 24 hours or so
joining me for the second hour of
uncensored still with me the former
adviser to Donald Trump one of them Dr
Jan Halper Hayes and from the talk I'm
pleased to say we joined the studio by
Nicola Thorpe and Mike Graham so do not
despair if you usually tune in at 9 00
pm to watch that they are both here to
give us their views uh let's talk then a
little bit about this your kind of uh
view of it Mike I mean you've been
watching politics for decades if I'm
allowed to say that many decades more
than me
and you are heralding the return of
trump well I'm not saying I'm heralding
the return of him but he's certainly
going to get the nomination for the
Republican party as a result of this I
mean I've been watching a lot of people
talking about this from inside the
Republican Party talking to some of them
myself and they all say look if he was
only 90 there he's now 100 there because
as you've been saying this is another
indictment it's just a serious if not
more serious than the last one that was
really serious and it's a kind of a show
trial as people have been saying it's
it's not going to do him any harm I
don't think he's doing him any good
perhaps in the country for the rest of
the Americans who don't vote for him and
who won't vote for him but he's it's
going to lock him in I think as a
republican candidate and and I think
that's unfortunate but if it's Trump
against Biden again I think it's really
unfortunate I think that's just a
hopeless choice for Americans it seems
somewhat unfortunate that those are the
two best options put forward I believe
the New York Times did a poll over the
last 24 hours and they had them if if
the presidential election was to take
place yesterday it would have been 43
Trump 43 Biden and actually quite a few
of the people polled requested was there
a third option they actually asked for
one even though none was given on the
polls I think it says a lot about where
Americans are at the moment let's have
that third option I mean I can sort of
sympathize with that sometimes I feel
like that in British elections too so
how much legal trouble is the former
president actually in and could he be
going to jail or one person has been
speaking out about Donald Trump's Legacy
and that's his former attorney Rudy
Giuliani
this one will be your legacy
violating the right of free speech of an
American citizen never mind whether he
was present or not it could be anybody
it could be a homeless person
you don't get to violate people's first
amendments right Smith no matter who the
hell you are or no matter how sick you
are with Trump derangement syndrome
and this isn't the first time you've
acted like an unethical lawyer it should
be the last
well let's use that as our jumping off
point shall we to go to Massachusetts
and speak to Donald Trump's former law
and all through the best-selling book
get Trump Alan dershowitz that Alan
thanks for making time with us again
this evening I I really enjoyed our
conversation yesterday I want to remind
uh our viewers of something you said
about the First Amendment uh where you
said people can have the right within
U.S Constitution to have a false opinion
or indeed a false idea
um have you had a development of your
thinking over the last 24 hours with
regard to reading that indictment since
then
well I've read it very carefully it's um
not the kind of indictment that should
be brought when it's being brought by
the man against whom Donald Trump is
running for president uh the incumbent
president's attorney general brought
this indictment and it should be the
strongest indictment in history before
you can go after the man running against
you otherwise you're interfering with an
election look I want to vote against
Donald Trump I voted against him twice I
have a constitutional right to vote
against him for the third time yes I
defended him but I defend a lot of
people I disagree with I disagree with
Donald Trump I disagree with Rudy
Giuliani
um but I don't think that this
indictment satisfies the First Amendment
and the sixth amendment to the
Constitution first amendment protects
the right to petition the government for
a redress of grievances Trump believed
he won the election he was wrong but he
petitioned the government and he failed
um also he had lawyers to help him and
they have been named design indicted
co-conspirators so the this indictment
dangers the right of defendants to have
zealous and creative lawyers and goes
after the lawyers too Trump's had a hard
time getting lawyers to defend them
because this group of lawyers on the
left in the United States that are
filing bar charges against anybody who's
ever defended him when I criticize that
group they filed the bar charge against
me and so what we see is an attempt to
intimidate lawyers I won't be
intimidated I'm too old for that but I'm
going to fight for the right of people
who I disagree with and want to vote
against so I'm hoping this indictment
will not result in a conviction it would
be bad for America and bad for our
freedom of speech I think you've got the
the rights of the American people and
the American voters at the Forefront of
your mind there do you feel like they
are being duly protected not only in the
criminal justice system at the moment
the way this process is playing out but
in the way that politics is happening
around them do you think they're getting
a fair whack at life with these types of
people and get in power
no I think that both sides are going to
lose in the end the American people are
going to lose because today it's going
to be the Democrats that go after the
Republicans tomorrow will be the
Republicans going after the Democrats
already we're seeing Republicans calling
for the impeachment of uh of Joe Biden
on unconstitutional grounds I would
defend Joe Biden as vigorously as I
defended president Trump against an
improper impeachment both sides are
weaponizing the legal system for their
own partisan advantage and the losers
are the American people who who have
their rights suffer in the process the
right of free speech the right of
political Association the right to
petition and the right to have counsel
we are a weaker democracy today than we
were before this all happened I wouldn't
bring all other American guests that we
currently have standing by in on this
then to get their their response to the
points that you just made Dr Jan uh
helper Hayes and Joe Walsh still joining
us down the line uh Dr Jan I'll start
with you based on what we were just
hearing there from from Alan do you
agree uh that the American public are
being sold short here absolutely
absolutely well the fact is that I think
we have very immature politicians that
really play Petty games and they have
not served the people for a number of
decades and for this game to keep on
going just like the russia-russia Russia
hoax Etc it really takes it's a
distraction which they want to do from
what the real issues are
coming to Joe Walsh now to get your
views from the US of course as a former
Republican Contender for nomination
yourself or for presidency and just as a
U.S citizen do you agree with what Alan
dershowitz said
look I appreciate what Alan dershowitz
said and I appreciate the fact that we
have to always be cognizant and Vigilant
of our justice system trying to
interfere with an election but we have
to balance that with the fact that no
one is above the law in this country not
even a candidate for president and I
need to emphasize this again look you
can disagree with what's in this
indictment but don't say that Donald
Trump was indicted because of things he
said he's been indicted for things he
did you have a right to lie about the
election you don't have a right to
purposely lie in court filings about the
election that is what he is alleged
that's just one to have done that's a
crime that's something Trump did Alan uh
last night when we debated this idea you
said the answer to a false idea is the
marketplace of ideas not criminal
prosecution do you stand by that with
regard to what Joe is just saying
absolutely and um
the government has to prove under his
theory that Donald Trump actually
believed actually knew he had lost the
election and I know a lot of people who
are close to Donald Trump I'm not
associated with Donald Trump but I know
a lot of people who are close to them
they all believe that Donald Trump
actually talked himself into it and
believed that he had actually won the
election now
is that a defense you can call it the
stupid defense I'm so stupid that I
actually believed I won the election
when everybody knows I lost the election
but under the Supreme Court decisions on
First Amendment New York Times versus
Sullivan Etc there's a very very high
burden on the government even in civil
cases to show not only that he was wrong
but that he was maliciously wrong and in
the criminal case they may have to show
that he subjectively knew he was wrong
and that's going to be a hard Mountain
for the prosecution to climb and I think
ultimately they'll fail if that's the
test because I think Donald Trump for
whatever reason actually believe that
the election was stolen he was dead
wrong about that but the issue is not
whether he was right or wrong that's for
the marketplace of ideas the issue in a
criminal case is whether he actually
engaged in fraud actually engaged in
corruption and to prove fraud and
Corruption you have to prove subjective
intent but he actually knew that he was
lying when he said that he had won the
election I don't think they're going to
be able to prove that Joe you shake your
head go ahead no why I'm shaking my head
because
lindershwitz but I don't
implicit matter if Trump believed he won
it's a crime what Donald Trump is
alleged to have done was to pressure
state legislators to exceed their
constitutional Authority that is a crime
whether Trump believed he won the
election or not again it's on it's it's
on the actions of Donald Trump it
doesn't matter what he thought
it does matter what he thought if he
thought he had won the election then
it's not pressuring then it's asking
people to do the right thing just the
way I was asked to do the right thing in
2000 when I thought the election was
stolen from Al Gore by the butterfly
ballot in Florida and I represented uh
the Democrat of Palm Beach County and
the Court ruled I was wrong but nobody
asked that
U.S state legislators to exceed their
constitutional Authority that's okay to
ask them that's okay is let the court
say no they they're exceeding their
Authority but good lawyers press the
envelope very far and you know you now
think that they were being asked to
exceed their Authority he thought that
that was within their Authority and
there were people who supported that
view remember too that in Hawaii in 1960
um uh a judge ruled that the way to
challenge a presidential election is to
come up with an alternate slate of
electors so it all comes down to what
Donald Trump actually believes
but if he did things based on his belief
they're not crimes just a point on the
burden of proof uh point you bought out
there as well uh you know I'm not saying
that Mike Pence is going to be
testifying in court but he's Come Out
Swinging very vocally against Donald
Trump and saying you know when it came
to that both count stuff there was like
oh everybody gaggle of of lawyers and
you know everything else he's basically
come out and debunked Trump's version of
events do you no no he hasn't he has the
question that he'll be asked by the
defense on cross-examination did Donald
Trump ever look you in the eye and admit
that he knew he had lost the election
and Pence will have to answer that
question honestly no he always said he
won the election he was wrong he was
dumb he was perverse but he always said
he won the election and Pence maybe
asked you did you believe that I don't
know if that's admissible or not but if
he's asked if he believed it I think
Pence will say yeah I believe that
that's who Trump is he actually thought
he won the election he was dead wrong so
I don't think they have a Smoking Gun
here let's remind of you as Mike
Pentacles was vice president under Trump
let's take a listen to what he just said
I want the American people to know that
I had no right to overturn the election
and then on that day president Trump
asked me to put him over the
Constitution but I chose the
Constitution and I always will
I mean I I
I really do believe that Anyone who puts
himself over the Constitution should
never be president of the United States
there we go that was Mike Pence speaking
there and according to Alan dershowitz
of course when he does uh testify in
this and myth and when we do see that uh
he will be asked straight in the eye
whether or not uh Trump typically please
think I mean I'm paraphrasing dershow
it's terribly here but you heard it
there yourself Let's cross to our panel
live now Mike Graham Nicola Thorpe and
uh let's discuss what you were thinking
there still joined in the studio as well
by Dr Jan
um you're listening to that argument no
might play out
um
when it comes to the way this is tried
do you have faith with your knowledge of
the US I know you go there a lot as well
as work there a lot and you cover it as
a journalist that we will see a trial
that plays out fully and or do you think
we're going to see some sort of bargain
before we get well I think it will play
out but I think the problem here is it
shows very good illustration of why you
can't politicize you know uh the law and
you can't use the law to make political
points because basically as Anne dushman
said there uh it's all about what Trump
believed you can't say that he made a
false claim and therefore that is in
some way against the Constitution
because it's not because they've said it
isn't now if if Joe's right and he says
well it's not about what he said it's
about what he did but again uh as Ellen
says if he knew that he thought that he
had won the election he was not breaking
the law by asking people to investigate
it he was asking them to do the right
thing because he thought that the
election had been stolen but let's face
it all these people like Joe as well
who's being a bit holier than now about
Donald Trump and saying you know this
man was trying to bust up something that
had been freely freely voted on you know
the Democrats have been doing that for a
long time lots of people have done it in
America lots of people have done it hang
on Joe lots of people have done it in
this country you know you're talking
absolute rubbish absolute cobblers Joe
go ahead
well for the first time in American
history a sitting American president
didn't have the balls to accept his
intellectual loss he didn't have the
balls or the distance why does that
bother you so much
you're telling me I'm holier than thou
you are this guy tried to end our damn
democracy
off why don't you move on and just get
over it Joe get over it get over it a
man is going to be the Republican Party
nominee and he has a shot and you're
helping him and you're helping him
country but you're helping him Joe
you're helping him back to the White
House you're helping him back to the
White House with you holier than now
attitude it's ridiculous American
history who else has done this nobody
else has done it to anybody else either
because Trump is yours is do you think
about Trump when you go to sleep at
night you have nightmares about him you
know move on man what
what president in American history
refused to participate in the peaceful
transfer Bower tell me well you know the
answers to that Joe don't you but you're
so upset about Donald Trump that you
can't leave it be
of course he's upset about Donald Trump
did to this country it's a great show
you do like yourself you do look as if
you're not taking this you know like
somebody who is neutral you look as if
you're obsessed with Trump and you want
to stop him from ever becoming president
ever again I think that's right isn't it
tell us that's not right make him held
accountable for what he did if that's
obsessed then I'm obsessed so you want
to stop him from getting back into the
White House though don't you look well
if he committed crimes if he did Michael
iffy right I want him held accountable
for them sure that he did now no no I
believe he did but Michael we have a
process here he's going to have his day
in court and if a jury of his peers
believe he committed crimes I want him
held accountable don't you look
Mike you've made your point uh Joe's
allowed himself to defend himself as
well is he helping Trump get into the
White House I think Joe would probably
disagree that he's going to stay with us
Joe Walsh throughout the show so we can
come back to him and get thoughts as
well from the rest of our panel
uncensored next tonight we're going to
be joined by one of Donald Trump's
longest serving advisors as we continue
our live coverage of this extraordinary
story
[Music]
thank you
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for at what appears to
be an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty KTM that would make her a better
princess of wealth because you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people
Elaine Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off shorts
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drug you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV is
about you and your opinions if you're
thinking about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
bring you back to unscented if you're
just tuning in former president Donald
Trump is appearing currently before a
judge in Washington DC but is expected
to enter a not guilty plea in relation
to four charges fought against him
earlier in the week this is third
indictment I remind you of that well for
more on what this means we're going to
continue to bring your life pictures
from the courthouse in DC we're joined
by uh political strategist and lobbyist
Michael Caputo
former Republican 2020 presidential
candidate Joe Walsh still joins us kind
of you to stay with us from the previous
conversation and joined in the studio
still by the former advisor to Donald
Trump Dr Jan Halper Hayes and talktv
presenter Nicola Thorpe and Mike Graham
they're both still with me so we've got
plenty of voices let's start there with
Michael caputa voice we haven't heard
from yet uh and I mean what I find most
interesting about your insights into
this is that you were heavily involved
in the Russia gate investigations that
happened prior
um and you have made some points to us
about the way that that affected you in
terms of legal fees and I'm interested
to know from you how you think that
changes things or or the way it shapes
the way we look at how Trump is fighting
these current indictment charges
well I think in America we call this
whole strategy law fair I think you
might call it the same over there and my
you know our society is becoming quite
you know dead into the pain of lawfare
really it's about punishing your
opponent with as much legal fees and and
accusations and charges and terrible uh
media Cycles as as humanly possible our
family was crushed by our legal fees
hundreds of thousands of dollars and I
was just a witness there are some like
Roger Stone or into the millions of
dollars and uh in reality these are all
a lot but you know these uh you know the
the charges against Trump Now remind me
of all the allegations against us it's
really political speech and they just
you know this is a a weaponization of
the federal government to fight and and
try to defeat Donald Trump before he
defeats Joe Biden that with the word
weaponization has been used so much
within the last week or the last few
days since this indictment lay latest
one drops anyway I've heard it uh you
know likened to the McCarthy era in
terms of exploiting paranoia and fear
with regards to interrogating and
investigating people we're talking
Russia gate now as well but in terms of
the funding you're in a very different
situation you say you're a witness to
that but it crippled your family with
regards to defending yourself as a
witness in Russia gate
Donald Trump is in a very different
position he is a was anyway you could
say are you still a successful
businessman he was former president
United States his Affairs his tax
Affairs have been revealed it's all very
complicated he is raising funds of
course for his campaign
um explain to an international audience
how he's probably going to fund this
type of Defense
well you know this is really part of the
issue the Department of Justice is
pursuing the very likely candidate after
the Republican primary who will run
against Joe Biden or any other candidate
they may have and they're trying to
him before he gets there part of
that is to drain the funds and and
distract the candidate and we know that
there's been millions of dollars in
legal fees in the past I mean these uh
indictments are getting to be like that
movie of Groundhog Day but it's not Bill
Murray it's Donald Trump and it it isn't
funny it's not a comedy uh in fact this
is very dangerous stuff you know this uh
first charge that Jack Smith came up
with the conspiracy against rights
charge includes a penalty of up to 10
years in federal prison but if a death
results to the from the conspiracy
against rights uh that that they can
also seek the death penalty the
conspiracy against right shards rises
from the January 6th uh Riot and Ashley
Babbitt was killed by the Capitol Police
in fact if these charges and especially
the conspiracy against rights charge uh
sticks they're seeking the death penalty
look at this trial this indictment
rather that we're hearing about now it
does cap off this years-long
investigation into the events of January
6 we're gonna have to wait and see from
the indictment from The Trial that
pursues we've obviously got the 45 pages
to read the details they've brought up
but you're right so Michael in saying
that it's not a comedy this it is very
real I just want to bring the audience
the latest breaking news from inside the
audience from inside the courtroom
rather the magistrate has now arrived
the hearing started Trump and the rest
of the courtroom Rose the court clerk
called the case the U.S of America the
United States of America versus Donald J
Trump the judge asked the former
president to give his name he stood up
even though he didn't need to he said
Donald J Trump and he has now been sworn
and we'll bring the latest details from
the courtroom as when they get to us but
I want to come back to the studio to Dr
Jan Harper Hayes who stayed with us
through some of the debates we've been
have being and talk to you a little bit
about the argument in fact that Mike
Graham who's to your right here in the
studio is having with Joe Walsh and will
bring him back in shortly
um with regard to whether this is all
helping Trump back into the White House
oh absolutely let's see what people
aren't also reporting on is that on
September 12 2018
Donald Trump filed executive order
13848 within that it had to do with
foreign and domestic election
interference in that he predicted what
would happen with 2020. I'm not willing
to conclude that he's not guilty or he
is guilty but when I have these
different facts I want to figure out
what is the real message because when
things are reported often it's to
distract us from the truth this has
helped Trump endlessly and the other
thing is is that he's going to be able
to present his evidence if he truly
believes that 2020 was rigged coming to
you now with some more breaking news
Donald Trump has just fled not guilty
for all Council those are the four
counts that are contained within the
this latest indictment that was very
much expected and certainly it was never
get to a stage of sort of bargaining on
a point of admitting that I mean Nicola
coming to you in the studio no surprises
there no no surprises there and I just
wanted to ask Jan if this if you're
saying that this helps this indictment
helps Donald Trump drastically why are
you saying it's so politically motivated
why would it be so politically motivated
by the other side if you believe
actually in the long run this is going
to help Donald Trump wouldn't they
therefore not have brought about this
indictment knowing that it would have
been so helpful to him
you know what they're trying to destroy
him right and if you think about that
action and if you think about what
Einstein said the definition of insanity
is doing the same thing over and over
again and not succeeding that's what's
happened to them they are obsessed just
like Joe Walsh is just I'll tell you why
they're obsessed and you know I watched
obviously that debate between Mike and
Joe and I agree with Joe on this one
I'll tell you why people are so
emotionally invested in this is because
of the way that Donald Trump acted as a
president he mocked disabled reporters
he bragged about grabbing women between
the crotch please it feels very I won't
stop this feels extremely personal for
every single woman who watched a man
brag about speaking about women and
touching women in that way a man who's
found legally liable for sexual assault
recently it is very personal for every
single American to see somebody like
that have the potential to regain the
most powerful position
who's been listening into this
conversation Joe um yeah
what do you make of it well and and I
agree with what Jan said look this
indictment is going to help Trump
politically I believe that I don't even
believe it will just help him secure the
nomination
I believe it will help him get reelected
I could be wrong but that's what I
believe because what Jan believes is
what most Republican voters what Michael
Caputo said that there's this deep State
out to destroy him that's a powerful
narrative I think it's wrong but most
Republican voters believe it look Trump
has been accused of committing crimes to
overturn an election
do we just ignore that because he's a
candidate
do we just ignore that Mike well I don't
think you ignore it but I think you have
to ask why it's taken one two and a half
years if it was such a serious
allegation that was made at the time you
know there's always an excuse the
Democrats are now hiding behind the idea
that oh well we didn't want to bring any
charges at the time because it was too
uh aggressive a situation we didn't want
to make it any worse we didn't want to
throw any more uh fuel on the fire so we
waited two and a half years until he
declared that he was running again and
then we decided that was a good time to
do it well there is no good time to do
it if you're worried about the reaction
you know as well as I do Joe that half
of the country as you quite rightly say
believe that Trump is the victim of a
Witch Hunt half of the country believe
him to be a criminal you know
unfortunately America has found itself
in this place I don't know how it got
there and I don't know how you get out
of it but I think by continuing to try
and make out that Trump one after
another after another after another uh
case against him is going to somehow
ruin him it's never going to work he's
going to get stronger and stronger and
stronger but Michael I think you would
agree with me that it doesn't matter
what the American people think on either
side it really should be about the facts
and the law correct yeah it should be
about the facts a little but the law is
being politicized unfortunately and you
can't find two people who will agree on
opposite sides of the Trump argument
what the law actually is right you keep
saying it's about what he did but what
he tried to do was what he did he didn't
actually do anything because he wasn't
Victorious he wasn't successful and so
therefore it would be better for the
country I think and I have people my
friends I have family living in that
country right it'd be better for the
country to heal themselves and to move
on and to stop trying to victimize the
guy
true but if you try to rob a bank and
you're unsuccessful you've still
committed a crime my friend yeah but you
don't wait two and a half years before
you arrest somebody for doing something
I I wish they had come out a long time
ago I wish they hadn't gone through this
process I agree with you on that thank
goodness Mike do you really think though
that somebody alleged a criminal
Behavior you know we should just move on
well yeah because it's not criminal
Behavior you don't know it's criminal
behavior until you try it in a court
well no and the Constitution is is very
clear
um as as Joe has said the Constitution
protects the free speech of Donald Trump
I mean I'm very uncomfortable with this
idea of the wrong opinion or a false
opinion you know an opinion is an
opinion in the First Amendment
the reason they're in court is because
people don't agree about the law and you
have to try the case so it's wrong to
say that you broke the law because we
don't know that you broke the law until
it's been proven in a court of law that
he broke it and but you're saying that
if the perception of the laws differ
then how are we ever going to try
anything in a court of law if people can
agree with that also you have to also
you have to also so get the idea that in
a court of law in America you're talking
about very different situation and a
grand jury in Washington DC As Trump
says is an anti-trump grand jury the
lawyer who's going to represent uh the
country is going to be anti-trump the
judge in the case is anti-trump reported
by Barack Obama has already centered
some of the uh criminals from the the
night of the riot so longer terms of the
government asked for you know it's a
rigged situation let's bring in Michael
Caputo he's been patiently listening
along to that uh Michael
um is this a dummy indictment of the U.S
justice system
well I think this vindicates to all of
us who support Donald Trump or even uh
you know a real Justice that this
indicates really we need true reform at
the Department of Justice we need true
reform at the FBI the whole system is
totally screwed up uh there are people
that are deeply politicized who are
burrowed deeply into all of our federal
agencies but certainly all the national
security agencies and we know they're in
the FBI I think it inspires people
around trump it inspires me for example
to think about ways that we can reform
the Department of Justice to stop the
abuse of the FIS of Courts the way they
tore up Carter page for no reason you
know all the different tricks of the
trade that they've used and abused to
create these hoaxes these things need to
be reformed but beyond that these are
serious charges there's no question uh
that they're trying to politicize uh on
their time to criminalize political
speech and they're trying to criminalize
discussions between lawyers and their
client but we have have real problems in
America where a lot of people in my
family the families around me don't know
what's next after this you know they've
tried everything against Donald Trump I
thought the only thing they haven't done
is you know arresting well then they've
done that more than once you know the
last time I saw him it was moments after
he was arraigned in Miami at a prayer
meeting you know for some reason or
another he's a Boolean after these
things he gather strength from
challenges and he knows a lot of people
are praying for him he knows a lot of
people are behind him we all know we've
talked about it it's 50 50 in America
and I think that in the end we're going
to a place where nobody's backing down
nobody's trying to pull up Donald
Trump's never going to quit I've known
him for 30 years he's not quitting so
where are we headed and America is
really worried about this we'll be
exploring that question further on in
the show Michael caputa it's been great
having your insights thanks for making
time Joe Walsh staying with us he's been
a trusty reaction to all of them right
and our panel stay with us in the studio
as well and centered next tonight is
former president Donald Trump sorry I'm
going to say this is very serious please
not guilty in relation to four charges
to January 6 2021 the uprising chat in
the capital we're joined by Louise men
she's made time for us as well we'll be
hearing from her next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back constantive to our special
show we've got for you covering the
latest Trump indictment that's happening
currently in Washington DC if you're
just tuning in let's remind you what's
happening Donald Trump's appeared before
a judge in that courtroom in DC where he
has entered a not guilty plea in
relation to four charges that were
brought against him over the 2020
presidential election now we're showing
you pictures from live outside Court
there are supporters there are
detractors there are some arguing that
by this point third indictment in we're
not quite getting the same level of
reaction but as you can see there it's a
pretty orderly crowd nothing untoward
has happened yet from inside the
courtroom the judge was actually uh 15
minutes 19 minutes rather late into
court before the court was in session
the gavel was banged Trump stood up with
his lawyers and everyone else at the All
Rise order he has pled guilty to all
four charges that have brought before
him in this current in indictment and we
did actually hear from his lawyer
outside the courtroom
your last name's Trump it's very
different so Hillary Clinton could have
a problem when she lost the election and
we could have a complete liberal
meltdown as we all saw but when we have
dignified disagreements we take them to
court we say do things patriotically and
peacefully he's to blame for things that
he did not himself do and that's what
we're seeing frankly folks this is not
about that this is about politics this
is about 2024. well for more
conversation join now by former British
conservative MP Louise mench who's based
Stateside and still with me here in the
studio talk TV presenters Nicholas
Thorpe and Mike Graham I've been
bringing us a lot of lively discussion
and chat throughout the last hour of
course they're normally on the talk at
this time it's very very kind of them to
share the studio this evening but
obviously Donald Trump does demand this
kind of attention from all these great
guests we've had so far let's get over
to Louise now and get your reaction to
what we've been seeing so far do you
think it's fair to say the reaction has
been somewhat more muted to this
indictment despite the fact that charges
could are more serious
I don't think that's actually true if
you look at the media coverage over here
everybody over here on the American TV
channels on the American newspapers is
talking about this as the most serious
of the probably four indictments that
he's going to face with one to come in
Georgia so although you're seeing
perhaps the crowd is a bit more muted
because now it's another day it's
another Donald Trump indictment that's
not the case when it comes to the media
coverage of the event look one of the
big debates we've been having the last
two nights and we've been talking about
this is this First Amendment right to
free speech to have what's called a
false opinion or a false idea this of
course is at the heart of whether Trump
really believed what he was saying when
he uh demanded recounts or said that
votes weren't as they were and it's
whether he believed it and then
delivered that truth to his followers
and supporters or whether he didn't
believe it but still spouted it anyway
and it's gonna be a very very hard thing
to test in court is what we've been
hearing talk to us about how you think
this will be approached and where you
think it's going to be won or lost
well sometimes I think some of the
commentators and guests on your show
haven't actually read the indictment
because Jack Smith the special counsel
makes it completely clear that he
believes he is accusing Donald Trump of
knowingly lying about the election which
by the way he says he's allowed to do
Under the First Amendment but then
converting that into a conspiracy by
using those lies to pressure State
lawmakers to go against the Constitution
for example to tell the governor of
Georgia that he just needed to find
exactly the right amount of votes to get
him over the top
um by trying to interfere in the
counting of votes by trying to pressure
Mike Pence into changing the results of
the election that's what's not legal in
America
um and I think it was Mike who said that
it is absolutely not legal in America
that's a crime it's a conspiracy against
rights and when you do that when you try
to overturn a legitimate election you're
actually taking away the votes of
everybody who vote for the other guy and
who actually beat you and that's what
Jack Smith says he's going to approve in
court so we can say well did he Believe
it or didn't he believe it the
indictment's really clear in the first
two sentences it says that Donald Trump
was knowingly lying when he pushed this
line and that he was doing it to try to
overturn an American election that's why
this is so serious just getting uh some
live updates from within the courtroom
that the hearing has now finished Trump
will next be in court on August 28th and
he's been ordered not to speak with
Witnesses in the case Louise
I think that's going to be very
difficult if there's one thing we all
know about Donald Trump is that he does
love to speak doesn't he does love to if
not tweet send out his messages on Truth
social
um and as with Michael Cohen in the past
he's been accused of uh contacting
Witnesses this judge is um Fair she was
a former public defender but she's not
going to have any nonsense from Donald
Trump or any other defendant in her
courtroom so that's the condition that I
think he'll find difficult to obey but
he probably will do his best to obey it
given the legal danger that he's in
Let's cross life back to Joe Walsh as
well trustee Joe Walsh is still there in
Washington DC for us to talk about that
and whether or not we do think Trump is
going to be able to comply with those
conditions of course not to speak with
witnesses as Louise said might be tricky
given he loves his tweets or his truth
socials rather
I I think generally he will I think the
next 15 months are going to be all about
Donald Trump I think any of any and all
of his Republican candidates are toast I
think that I think it's over
um and I again I as an opponent of
Donald Trump
I'm not convinced that these Luis is
right it will be four indictments
against him I'm not convinced that these
will hurt him in a 50 50 country he
could get reelected people need to
understand that Louise is he the other
contenders toast DeSantis that's it boom
gone
no I think you have to I don't agree
with Joe that he's got a decent chance
of getting elected he's got a very good
chance of winning the primary I think
he's absolutely toast in the general
election Independents didn't want him in
2020 how much less likely are those
independent voters those swing marginal
voters that make the difference how much
less likely are they to go for him when
he's under every indictment known to
mankind and as it was mentioned earlier
has lost a civil case where he was
accused of sexual assault uh women are a
very important voting block I don't
think personally he's got a chance in
the general election and that's why I
think that just maybe down the line
Republican voters they might come to
their senses and say look we really hate
Joe Biden we love Donald Trump but we
hate Joe Biden more and maybe they will
start looking at an alternative
candidate that can actually win the
election because one thing I do know if
Donald Trump is the nominee Joe Biden is
going to win 2024 in a landslide and how
badly do the GOP Primary voters really
really want that when it comes down to
it when we're closer to the election
than we are now yeah that is the other
argument let's bring a mic in the studio
because we've heard you know you
accusing Joe of kind of helping Trump
back to the White House but the other
argument here is that all of this and is
happening is actually helping Biden
secure the nominations the trouble with
with all of that though is that yeah if
it's Trump against Biden it's a
two-horse race and any political analyst
will tell you worth his weight or her
weight in gold uh is it for two horse
race anybody can win it you know
something could happen to Joe Biden you
know he's not exactly in the full
fullness of Health at the moment if he's
expected to go for another four years
he's supposed to go through another
campaign if you get the last campaign
was held during covert he didn't go
anywhere didn't even go out on the stump
nobody saw him he was hiding in a
basement most of the time so in the end
you know if you've got the Democrats the
best thing that they can provide is Joe
Biden I think people will will be
horrified by by the general spectacle of
all of it and they'll just go we don't
really want to vote for anyone maybe
it'll be a low turnout and the Trump
could maybe win that way so I don't
think you could be sure about writing
anybody off I think but I do agree with
Joe that I think this is no doubt that
Trump is now the nominee for the
Republican party it can't be anything
else well Nicola you were talking
earlier on about the third option wish
that some American voters could have but
if they were presented with Trump or
Biden yeah I mean Biden is it really
that terrible I don't know I I mean like
he he won four years ago three years ago
and I don't know if he was that much
healthier back then I think it was all a
little bit but at the at the end of the
day I think that Trump is still so much
more the worst option in the majority of
American people's eyes and the sensible
people's eyes I mean over here in this
country it's mad to me the way we see it
and yes we are onlookers we're not
living in that country but the way we
see it we go America must be mad to even
consider getting Donald Trump back but
again we look at Joe Biden and say that
would be really difficult if that was
our prime minister also remember back to
2016 when Trump won
um you know nobody thought he would I
mean there was absolutely no chance of
him winning that election he was written
off right up until practically the end
right so I think those in glass houses
shouldn't throw stones we don't have a
brilliant one in the UK so I mean
fascinating and fantastic candidates I
would argue in the last few years or so
anyway on sense of next tonight we'll
have the latest from Washington DC's
former president Donald Trump appears
before the Elijah Barrett Prettyman
Federal kelt house to answer those four
felony charges to which he has pled not
guilty
foreign
[Music]
Trump yeah look at him fail stop working
just because their skin folk don't mean
they're kinfolks do you believe you can
win this war but it's making me cry
again I'm trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for at what appears
an abuse of power
when they first got together there were
press stories weighty Katie that would
make her a
burying the man
Elaine Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they've bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know I know you're probably going
to vote me off charts
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about yeah
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV is
about you and your opinions if you're
thinking about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored We are
following the motorcade this is Donald
Trump's motorcade the fourier's presence
making its way through a tunnel back to
an Airfield in Washington DC where he's
going to hop foot it back onto his Trump
plane back out to Bedford to New Jersey
the safety of home well could we expect
a speech from him when he gets home
we've seen it happen before when he's
back on the golf course some comments
from him because we haven't heard from
him outside Washington DC courthouse
where he'd had his hearing for his third
indictment today played not guilty to
those four charges contained but then
just to remind you of how that all went
down he made his way promptly into the
courthouse with his team we heard from
his lawyer beforehand then arrived there
the judge was 19 minutes late slammed
the gavel down ask them to rise they all
Rose in the courtroom we can't bring
your pictures because there were no
cameras Donald Trump Rose said his name
pled not guilty has been told to not
communicate with Witnesses and to return
to court on August 28th will of course
bring you any more details as and when
we get them no fireworks but plenty of
supporters and detractors outside the
courtroom today thank you so much for
joining us for the last two hours or so
we have had some really fascinating
debates back with me is the former
Republican 2020 presidential candidate
Joe Walsh and still with me here in the
studio talk TV presenters Nicola Thorpe
and Mike Graham and Louise Mensch still
joining us Stateside as well for this
final wrap-up discussion and what we
want to ask you just to kick things off
as we think about how this is all
heading is whether or not you think we
are going to see a conviction of trump
in any of the criminal trials or the
Civil trials coming there are numerous
counts loaded up against him here and
whether or not you will see him elected
and a reminder here that those two
things are not separate he can still run
for the White House even if he is
convicted apparently can still be
president from jail Nicola what do you
think we're going to see
oh I I mean I certainly hope that we
will not be seeing that but it would not
surprise me but like as Mike said just
before we hit the break nobody thought
that Trump was going to become president
in 2016 it took a lot of us by surprise
it would not surprise me if this
happened again what I think is such a
shame is that this has become a First
Amendment Free Speech issue when it was
made so clearly as Louise just said
earlier on in Jack Smith's indictment
that it was not about his Free Speech it
was not about his opinions it was the
actions that he took and actually Jack
Smith indictment was so restrained there
were two other charges that he could
have put on there he could have put on
seditious conspiracy and rebellion and
Insurrection they were absent from that
charge sheet and yet this is going to be
is he going to be is he gonna be in the
White House
no Mike she doesn't want him to be in
the white house it's not the same thing
I think the problem with the with the
indictment is that there's a reason why
he didn't make those two charges because
he didn't think that he could make them
stick and as Alan dershowitz said his
word I would say on the law before
anybody else is on the show tonight uh
is that you know you can't prove what
somebody was thinking you can't prove
that they deliberately did something
because that's an incredibly difficult
thing legally uh to to get across the
line look we are running oh desperately
short of time here we do need to hear
these polling our informal talk TV
uncensored poll this evening Louise
Mensch do you think we're going to see
conviction do you think we're going to
see election
yeah let me just put it this way Donald
Trump is not going back to the White
House Donald Trump is going to federal
prison and in my opinion he will be
convicted on three of the four charges
he might get out of the nothing burger
from Alvin Bragg in New York all of the
others he's going to be convicted on
especially this one and this is his
journey to prison not back to 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue okay Joe you've been
a legend for sticking with us for two
hours this evening up against lots of
trump supporters uh yes uh or no
convicted elected
I don't think we'll see any verdicts
before the 24 election I think there's a
decent chance Trump will be re-elected
there's evidence he committed crimes to
overturn the 2020 election for people
saying we should just move on then
they're saying that Donald Trump is
above the law nobody in America should
be above the law and that strikes right
back to what we were talking about at
the start of the show the minds of the
American people the voters the people
that matter here hopefully not being
lost in all of this thank you all so
much for giving us your view there the
poll coming up at the top of the hour is
first edition as ever with Phil Gale
Phil hi drama out the US what do you got
coming up tonight yeah yes well of
course we'll we'll continue with uh
following the Trump circus as he is uh
arraigned in Washington we'll speak to a
trump loyalist who claims this is a
Witch Hunt and will also hear from a
moderate Republican and of course we'll
look at today's Bank of England interest
rate increase what can the government
what should the government do to help
people with more images and we'll have a
look at tomorrow's papers today with our
first edition panel all that at the top
of the hour thank you so much Phil do
stay tuned to us here on talktv for that
want to thank all of the amazing guests
that we've had throughout the last two
hours giving us their view from those
States and also here in the UK we've had
our panelist Richard Paul Isabel in the
studio mike and Nicholas in the last
hour as well so you haven't even missed
out on the talk either and we do have
the motorcade still heading back to that
Airfield in Washington DC Donald Trump
making his way to the safety of his
Trump plane and back to the safety of
Bedminster New Jersey a classically long
motor cave there for the man that is
never knowingly understated that is it
from me whatever you're up to make sure
it's uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]